[Music]
mariah carey's twins rock and roll are
taking after their mama rock n roll love
being on the stage um and that on that
on that song always be my baby i have
you know the visuals behind them of them
and so they get kind of like they want
to watch themselves but they want to be
on the stage so actually the other day i
was just teaching
miss monroe the
you'll always be a part of me
and just singing like that to her and
she has a really good ear so she was she
was learning it the kiddos joined mom
for a fun sing-along to the 2002 hit
with busta rhymes i know what you want
and the caption on the clip eternally
12. yes darling now some might find that
phrase confusing but real lambs know
this diva keeps things timeless and
considers herself to be well eternally
12. i don't know numbers okay stop
trying to age me yeah mariah doesn't
celebrate birthdays instead she
acknowledges anniversaries i'll never
get over it but back to that tick tock
[Music]
this isn't the first time mariah's
collaborated with them babies who we
should probably be calling them tweens
check out this vid from a couple years
back robe seemingly hitting a high note
[Music]
mommy
what you said do the high
notes but then mimi proves she's the one
with the vocals isn't that exciting the
canon kiddos have also joined in tick
tocks to get out the vote to promote
mommy's memoir and even sing along to
mariah's most famous song accompanied by
the family pets
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's festive yeah we look forward to
that christmas content every year and
judging by what mariah told et last year
there will be plenty more to come in the
holiday seasons ahead mariah you look
like you are in your christmas glory i
love this if them babies don't enjoy
christmas i don't know who does okay i
spend the whole year figuring it out
and you know look they do enjoy
christmas we ski they go i mean we ski
they ski i take one run down the
mountain and i'm good
they snowboard they do everything they i
mean like look whatever you want to say
oh can you see this can you see this
here let me see uh-uh let's go blankie
and this is out this year like it's got
the puppies and there's the real puppy
cha-cha
there's my little plushy girl
oh here you go molly yes molly come here
it's kevin
oh
yeah he's kind of he's kind of clunky
but
anyway we're all here we have the best
time at christmas we go to aspen every
year we it has to snow like even the
thing i love about that is that even if
it doesn't snow you're literally looking
at mountains with snow
[Music]
you